- Excellent. Hey
everybody, how's it going?
- [Audience] Good.
- First day of re:Invent
going well so far?
(audience cheering)
- Woo! Thank you.
Thank you for attending.
I know there's a lot of
things on your schedule
that are probably conflicting with this.
You are our people, so thank
you for prioritizing operations
and incident management
over all of those activities
that are happening in the
expo center right now.
So, this is the more valuable one by far.
So, just to get things started,
this is not going to be
a slide-heavy presentation.
Nora and I are just going
to be spending a lot of time
talking about different concepts
associated with AI and operations.
So, we're gonna try and keep
this a little bit more casual.
So, to set the stage, what we'd like to do
is actually get a selfie
with everybody in the room.
So, if everybody could
just lean in a little bit,
I'm gonna use my extendable arm here
and grab a picture of
everybody real quick.
All right, smile. Thanks, everybody.
Excellent. All right.
- Awesome.
- Let's dive in.
- Thanks y'all. All right, so,
thank you again for coming.
Like Tom said, we know this is
the last session of the day,
the first day of re:Invent, and
we are going to keep it fun.
We've known each other for
several years now, I think.
- Five.
- And we've bonded over the topics
that we're talking about today.
And we thought the best way to do this
is to kind of have, you
know, a great conversation
about these topics like we like to do.
So, I'm Nora Jones.
I am a VP of product
development here at PagerDuty
and I'm joined today by Tom Leaman,
who is VP of site reliability engineering
at one of our amazing customers
and who has been a fantastic
partner to us at PagerDuty
over the years, Warner Bros. Discovery.
- Thank you, Nora.
Like Nora mentioned, Tom Leaman,
VP of site reliability engineering.
Just to level set,
because I think everybody
has their own definition
of site reliability engineering.
What that translates into
at Warner Bros. Discovery
is that our SRE teams
handle all of the engineering solutions
for what we consider proactive
and reactive reliability,
database reliability, FinOps,
and site reliability operations,
which is our incident management
and analytics function.
And, we support HBO Max,
Discovery Plus, TNT, you name it,
any of our DTC, direct
to consumer products
that happens to be within the bounds
of site reliability engineering at WBD.
- Amazing.
And, today we're gonna
be having a conversation
around, you know, a favorite topic
that's happening right now,
which is AI-driven automation
for modern operations.
We've spoken a lot as an industry
and we've been using AI over
the past several years now,
and it's really escalated recently.
But we wanna talk today
about how we can leverage
it a little bit more
in operations and within
resiliency and reliability.
We talk about how it
impacts reliability a lot,
but how can we leverage
it to our advantage
when we are in some of
these emergency situations?
Or even when we're in the context
of more well-understood
situations as well?
And so, I know Tom has gone on
a lot of a journey with this,
even within Warner Bros. Discovery.
You've been there for four years now
and you've done a huge
technology shift internally, too,
which we'll get into in a little bit.
But even within PagerDuty, you know,
we've been working with
a lot of our customers
for a long time now, and
we're seeing how the folks
that are adopting AI and
automation are resolving
and responding to incidents better
and more confidently than, you know,
folks that are not
leaning into it as much.
So for example, in 2025
we saw that enterprises
that increased their use of
PagerDuty AI and automation
actually had a faster
incident resolution time
by about 2.8x, which ended up totaling
to over six hours in 2025.
And part of the reason I'm so
excited to talk with Tom today
is Warner Bros. has been
a great partner to us
over the years.
You know, we've changed as the company,
the industry's changes, you know,
and Warner Bros. has changed as well.
And we've been really working together
to help you stay resilient
and to help us build a
platform that matters.
So first of all, thank you for that.
I'm curious, you know,
if you could get into
some of the shifts that you
have been experiencing recently
at Warner Bros., even
starting with when you joined.
- Yeah, absolutely.
So, I'm going to take a
trip down memory lane,
go back to about 2022, 2023,
around when Discovery Communications
and Warner Media merged together.
There was a decision that was made
that we would end up launching
a net new streaming application
called Max, now HBO Max.
There was also an HBO Max back then.
You've been through the journey with us,
I won't talk about that any more.
(Nora chuckles)
As a part of that process,
we had about a nine month deadline
to create and build this net
new streaming application.
And the intention was that
we weren't just going to take
one of our preexisting products,
whether it was the Discovery
Plus streaming application
or HBO Max as it stood
then, and then rebrand it.
Instead, we thought this
was a great opportunity
to establish a stronger consistency
with our technical platform
and engage engineers,
operators, product TPMs
in standardized processes
across our organizations.
So effectively what we did
was we built this platform
as a best of both worlds,
taking lessons learned from both locations
and aligning on a
similar technology stack.
I'm not gonna go into the
details of the architecture,
that's not the topic of this conversation.
But, a core part of what we did back then
was understand and align
on how we would describe our system.
Probably one of the most
foundational concepts
that we came up with at that point in time
was the operational metadata schema.
And this was a standardized approach
by which we catalog our services
and systems throughout the entirety
of the software development life cycle
so that we could easily understand
from the point of a
repository being created,
we could understand the
hierarchy of business functions
represented within that repository,
through the CICD pipelines
to our deployed infrastructure,
services, metrics, logs,
and eventually incidents
handled in PagerDuty.
We would carry through that metadata
that would identify the business function
like consumer, commerce,
playback capabilities,
down to the microservice that
it ended up tying back to.
This gives us really great traceability
when it comes to handling an incident,
when handling operations,
handling things like FinOps
and metering across the board.
Beyond that, which was very much
almost a vertical Conway's Law set up,
many of our organizations were
set up in a similar fashion.
We had this concept that we created
called the Critical User Journey,
and these were horizontal
slices of functionality
that were most important to our customers,
things like playing back
video, the ability to log in,
being able to browse and search.
So, we were able to map
many of these components
and microservices to those
customer user journeys.
This helped us prioritize our work,
how we would classify incidents,
and effectively drove a lot of our work
within the operations space.
- What I'm also hearing a lot
of in there is just, you know,
you had these two applications
and then you were building
another application,
but you also had two cultures
that you were merging
and then you were
co-creating a third culture
while launching this application.
And I'm also, you know,
I've been through this,
we've all been through a lot of this,
unless you're explicitly
putting it out there,
there are different assumptions
around what reliability means,
what the most important business value is,
and you might have actually
been experiencing that
with even these two different cultures.
And so, what I like about this
operational metadata concept
is it's like helping create
that common vernacular.
Who did you have in the room
when you were having these conversations?
- Yeah, so it was folks
from across technology,
product business that were all involved,
especially as we were defining
those Critical User Journeys
because at the end of the
day, you need the buy-in
from folks that are outside
of the technology space
to be able to actually provide input
on what we think those
most important functions
are going to be, and then back
that up with data as well.
So, this was actually a
very welcome conversation
across the board, that by
proactively engaging these groups
outside of engineering in
the process of operations,
it helped us get to common ground
as far as how we talk about
incidents and operations
and priorities across the board.
- Amazing.
So, this actually is a great segue
into some of how we've been talking
about different archetypes
that we might experience.
And, you know, if we
take it at a high level,
we can think of operational situations
fitting into one of three
archetypes or maybe a mix of two.
We have new and novel situations,
which we've all experienced a lot of,
and these will only increase
as we add new technology
and add new complexity
and businesses grow,
which are brand-new situations,
which require a human being
to put their expert attention into it.
We've partially understood situations,
which you know, seem kind of familiar,
maybe we haven't seen it in a long time.
Maybe the people that dealt with it
are not at the organization anymore.
And then we also have
well-understood situations.
These are things that, you know,
get us pulled into, you
know, day in and day out.
But they shouldn't require a human being
to necessarily interrupt their workflow.
And so, what you were kind of dealing with
with this new app that you
were launching in nine months
was sort of this new and novel situation,
which requires a lot of
communication as well.
Can you talk about how that got developed?
- Yeah, so a lot of it
boils down to investment
in that foundation because the
more that you can document,
the more conversations that you can have,
the more of that foundation
that you can build up,
like with the operational metadata,
the CUJs coming to those
types of alignments,
the fewer situations you'll run into
that are the new and novel domain.
- Mm-hmm.
- And when you are in the new
and novel space, you can
leverage a combination
of things like automation,
artificial intelligence,
standardized ways by
which you're organizing
your information, to
be able to disambiguate
and find some insights
to be able to suss out
some of those new and
novel situations itself.
- Mm-hmm, and you've sort of codified
what is important to the business
and are helping folks
that are on the ground
resolving the incidents understand it,
but helping the business
sort of form that alignment
with them as well.
How do you see that model evolving with AI
and how do you see AI playing a part
in helping folks understand, you know,
the operational model?
- Oh, absolutely.
So I think there's a really,
really solid opportunity,
and we're even leveraging
it internally as well,
is pointing agents at those
types of knowledge bases,
whether it happened to be
the OMD service catalog
that we happen to have
that provides this listing
of all of the different
business functions,
capabilities and
microservices to run books
that are stored in standardized locations
referencing that OMD taxonomy.
LLM agents that are
pointed at that information
can then be used by a
wide range of personas
to gain a better understanding
of what your system happens to be.
And, no more of an important time is there
than in the middle of an incident
to be able to get that type of context
because not every single
engineer in our organization
is going to be able to understand
the entire distributed system,
all of our business
functions across the board.
But what agents provide
is a quick and easy tool
to be able to provide that
access at their fingertips
versus trolling through
hundreds of wiki pages
- Right.
- Or dozens of dashboards.
- Which takes a lot of time
when you're trying to stop the bleeding
and get back to a customer's experience
as quickly as possible.
Has anyone in the room been
in the middle of an incident
or, you know, before an incident started
and everyone's kind of
debating what SEV level it is
or if it is even an incident?
Has that ever happened to folks?
Yeah, I feel like it's
a pretty common thing
and it keeps happening.
And so, what I like about
the approach you're taking
is it's evolving with the folks,
but it's also giving them
someone to gut check with
and that is kind of an
agent in those situations.
- Absolutely.
And we've started to see some
success with that already.
Recently, within the past
couple of weeks actually,
we just released into a internal beta
in our site reliability operations team,
a incident severity classification agent.
So by providing a lightweight description,
you can feed that into the agent
and it will actually reference
a lot of our documentation
associated with severity matrixes.
Now, pretty much everybody in the room
raised their hand earlier
about being in a debate
about incident severity.
I'm gonna ask for some participation here.
Why? Why do people debate severity?
Shouldn't it be clear cut?
You can just point to
a metric or a measure.
(attendee speaks indistinctly)
Absolutely.
So just to repeat back for
folks that are viewing remotely
or on the recording, one of the questions
or one of the contributing factors
can be lack of documentation
or lack of awareness of documentation,
or potentially even substantially
robust documentation
that nobody's going to
be able to actually parse
and understand in the middle
of an incident, right?
- [Nora] Or even know where
it is or what to look up
in some of those situations as well, yeah.
- Yeah, I know,
oh, we've got another
raised hand back there.
Yeah, so the response there
was we may have different capabilities
that are used by smaller
subsets of customers
versus an entire product application.
You know, certainly in
the context of HBO Max,
if playback is not working,
that is an absolutely critical issue.
If a smaller-used
functionality isn't working,
then that might be a lower severity issue.
Now, one thing that we have
to think about within WBD
is we support so many
different product lines
that something that would be a SEV One
for one of our product lines
may not be the same scale
as what we see on HBO Max, right?
It's not going to reach a,
"Hey, we can't play back a video
at 9:00pm Eastern on a Sunday night,"
for whether it be "Task" or,
you know, "Welcome to Derry"
or "House of the Dragon," right?
- Yeah.
And, I think that what
you had brought up earlier
was like a lot of this
is alignment, right?
And then when you're in
the middle of an incident
and you know that something is down,
time is precious, right?
And fumbling for docs
versus sometimes trusting your expertise
is a decision that's being weighed.
And I think a lot of what you're doing
and a lot of how we've seen you utilizing
and revolutionizing
some of your operations
is to make that discernment
easier for folks
no matter where they
sit in the organization.
Can you talk a little bit about that?
- Yeah, kind of going back
to the example that I gave
with the agent that we
just deployed recently,
one huge investment that we've put in
over the past couple of months
is those types of collaborations
with folks across the board
where we've had conversations
with key business leaders
and key engineering leaders
across each of our CUJs
to really suss out exactly
what incident classifications
could be within their particular domain.
So for playback, if this
happens to be the impact
or this subset of users or this platform,
or there's a regulatory issue,
or there happens to be an issue
associated with our observability platform
or deployment pipelines.
And we were able to work through
and collaborate with folks
because everybody understood
what was in it for them.
Because it removes that level of debate,
it removes that level of
lack of trust in the process
because you can actually
see it coming together.
Now, after we put all of that together,
we ended up with spreadsheets
that were hundreds of rows long
and the immediate reaction
was going back to it,
the documentation's too long,
no one's gonna be able to parse it,
but that's where the agent comes in
because an agent can parse it,
it can actually derive that value
and it can get it to you right
in the middle of an incident
without much of a problem at all.
- Right.
And I'm sure that also, you know,
even if you have new people on the team,
that likely can ramp them up more quickly
so that you have more
expertise in the mix as well.
- Oh, absolutely.
And lemme take a backtrack real quick.
There was a quote that I heard
as far as leveling someone up
when it comes to an
understanding of architecture.
How many of you have been onboarded
or helped onboard a person
and sent them a list
of around 15 to 20 wiki pages
and architecture diagrams
to get up to speed?
I see smiles, I see nods.
- Same business.
- We have all been there.
- Yeah.
- I, yes.
And then they go on a retreat, hibernate,
and then after winter is over,
they get thrown at their first incident
and the first thing they do is?
Page a senior engineer.
'Cause they don't know how
the system actually operates.
But, you throw someone
in that incident upfront,
they're gonna learn real fast.
- Right.
- Sure, they should have some help,
they should have some handholding.
You don't want somebody
that's responding to a SEV One
actually taking the reins
if they're, you know,
just straight out of college,
something along those lines.
But, you equip them in those positions,
whether it's through an
actual live incident,
whether you're recreating an
incident with fault injection
in a lower-level environment,
you equip them with an agent
that also has the
information at its fingertips
of past incidents, runbooks,
all of this information
and that individual can get up to speed
and understand the
context of what's going on
much, much faster.
It's effectively training
wheels for, you know,
when they're actually going
live and working independently
as on-call engineers and operators.
- And as an industry, you know,
for the last several years,
I think we've all been in companies
where we've experienced a major incident
and you know, as much
as you try to avoid it,
there're like three people you know
that you want in the
room helping you, right?
And I think what we're
seeing as an industry
and how we're evolving is
that we can kind of remove
knowledge silos a little bit.
We're disseminating knowledge
a little bit more readily
and leveling everybody up together
rather than leveling up people
in individual knowledge silos,
which can ultimately help our businesses.
I think one of the things that I,
so I was listening to your
podcast with Werner Vogels
around the frugal architect.
And one of the things
that you said on there
really stuck out to me because
I think it's so important
to keep in context, is that
we are doing reliability
not just for the sake of reliability,
not just for the sake
of keeping databases up,
but for the customer experience
and for customer trust.
And so, it sounds like
your operational model
actually helps disseminate
customer trust, all the way down
to what that means on a
service level as well.
And so I feel like that's
like very important
to keep in mind around, you know,
how you architect your processes, too.
And so you were mentioning
a little bit about SEV Ones
and SEV Twos and how they
follow certain processes.
Could you double click
into what the process is
for a SEV One?
- Yeah. So before diving into SEV Ones-
- Yeah?
- Why don't we talk
a little bit more about
just severities in general?
- Sure.
- The way that we operate,
we have four severity
classifications at Warner Bros.
SEV Ones and SEV Twos
are the most critical.
SEV Ones happen to be significant outages,
SEV Twos, we know a CUJ
happens to be impacted
in some way, shape or form for
a subset of our client base.
Threes and fours tend
to be very, very small
customer impact, if
not no customer impact.
So these could be situations
where you may have high memory utilization
or CPU utilization, you
should probably look into it,
but you know, the customer
experience is in a good space
in those situations.
So, based on that severity classification,
we'll actually handle those differently.
And so we track our time to acknowledge
and time to mitigate
measures very, very closely
for all of our incidents.
And for each severity type,
we have different SLAs associated
with each of those types of measures.
So time to acknowledge may
be a little bit more lenient
for SEV Threes and SEV Fours.
For SEV Twos and SEV Ones,
it's extremely short for time to mitigate.
Again, you know, those numbers come down
pretty substantially,
but also the expectations
associated with the process will evolve
based on that severity classification.
Threes and fours are largely landed
with the engineering teams.
And one thing we didn't
talk about yet is, you know,
our culture of incident operations at WBD,
we have very much the, you
build it, you run it function.
So while we do have groups
like the site reliability operations team,
which is there for every
incident to facilitate,
ensure that folks are following
the process appropriately,
we expect engineers that commit code
and develop the software to
actually respond to the pages
and be a core part of mitigation
of any type of incident
impacting their services.
So for SEV Threes and SEV Fours,
the SRO doesn't get involved.
Effectively that's an
engineering-only function.
Typically teams aren't paged for that,
although for SEV Threes, we
give them the opportunity to,
if they think that those
could potentially become
customer impacting down the road.
SEV Twos, these again are tied back
to some customer impact
associated with our CUJs
or some critical function
like legal, regulatory
or something that would
impact developer productivity
and back office functions.
Those will involve the site
reliability operations team.
They will facilitate the
process, page folks in,
we'll handle things like
stakeholder notifications,
note taking, the administration
of our PagerDuty incident
tickets to make sure
that things are in good order
as we're going through the incident itself
and when we close the incident out,
we've got the appropriate
metadata associated with it.
For SEV Ones, we add
on an additional layer
of expectation as a part of that process.
Not only are our time windows
much shorter on our SLAs,
but we actually kick in what
we call the technical call
leader rotation, which is
a dedicated response group
of VP and up leaders.
So these are individuals
that are involved in
providing executive level
communications across
the organization as well
as handling things like business decisions
and things along those lines.
So, as we go through
those severity levels,
we've ratchet up the
expectations, the responsibilities
and the folks that get involved.
- And it sounds like
you can leverage agents
or you are leveraging agents
to help with managing some
of those expectations depending
on the situation someone is in.
- Absolutely.
So, when we're looking at
a SEV Two for instance,
there is a very solid
opportunity to utilize agents
for things like those
status updates, right?
So in the middle of an incident,
things are complicated, right?
We're getting hit by changing
metrics, changing logs,
context from DMs that are coming
from the side channel conversations
and the chat that was spun up
specifically for the incident,
you may have a video conferencing bridge
that's set up as well.
There's a lot of information
and being able to discern that
into a well-structured update
that stakeholders across the
organization can understand
is no small feat.
So one area that we're looking at
and have lightly utilized
so far is using agents
to parse through certain
subsets of that data,
a combination of context from
conversations as well as some
of our operational data
to inform the details
of those status updates.
This significantly decreases
the toil from our operators
and reduces the amount of task switching
that's necessary in the
middle of an incident.
And this is certainly
beneficial when we're dealing
with a situation where we have
to do executive
communications, for instance.
So, being able to tie in automation
and agents to be able to
summarize the nitty gritty details
of a technology incident
such that it's understandable
across multiple business contexts
is an absolute game changer.
- Yeah, absolutely.
And you know, you mentioned like,
because executives aren't always
involved in every incident,
but SREs are, and so sometimes
when it goes into a new
process, it's like you haven't
practiced in a while, right?
And so it sounds like leveraging
agents to give you a leg up
to remember what executives
need in a situation, remember
what your customer service
folks need in a situation, like
you've brought up to me
before, you know, we have
our external customers, right?
And it's, you know, their experience
and their trust matters, but
we also sometimes in incidents
have internal customers as well that need
to know what's going on
to keep the lights on
and to keep things going.
- Yeah, absolutely.
And going back to the model
that you introduced before,
you know, no matter what type
of incident you're dealing with,
you're always going to have
that well-understood work.
What I was talking about before
with those status updates,
those are well understood pieces of work.
You know that your stakeholders are going
to expect messages every 15
minutes, every 30 minutes,
and there's a synthesis
process associated with that.
- Right.
- But beyond that well understood work
where agents typically are able, you know,
sometimes you can hand the
reins over to the agent as long
as you have a person saying yes,
that's an appropriate
message to send an executive
or to stakeholders.
There's also the concept of how agents
can better inform the incident response
of the responders, the
operators, the engineers
when they don't have
much context associated
with the incident or the functionality
that they're dealing with.
Again, I'm gonna lean into that.
WBD has a very complicated
ecosystem from a business as well
as a technology perspective.
So being able to keep track
of every single release,
every product function that
goes live is not something
that any engineer or any
leader is able to parse through
or keep in their memory's
short term cache.
But, an agent can, it can use retrieval,
augmented generation, it
can pull in information
from your wiki docs.
So, we've been in situations
where we've been managing incidents
and it is very, very
easy to turn to an agent
and ask questions about some
of what is being talked about.
In the case that you aren't familiar
with the discussion topic.
We had recently launched a capability
called, let's see, what was it?
Limited Free Experience.
And I wasn't super familiar
with that on the line.
And the acronym was being used
because who doesn't love a good acronym?
So it was LFE, and it was
some of the first times
that I had heard it, and
immediately I started seeing
the acronym that I
didn't understand, turned
to my handy dandy agent,
and immediately gave me back a report that
provided information on the
capability in that circumstance
to be able to actually
help better understand
ton hat helped me provide a better impact
the incident itself.
So, a lot of good opportunities,
whether we're talking
about not well understood
to very, very well understood.
- And, I think you
brought up a good point.
Like we could be in a
new and novel situation,
but part of the resolution of
that could be well understood,
maybe like how we need to
provide status updates to folks.
And so it's not necessarily, you know,
and if we're looking at
this whole life cycle
that we see on the screen,
it's not necessarily
that everything needs to
fall under one archetype.
It's that, you know, part
of these things could
be helped with agents.
I'm curious, you know, if
we're thinking about, you know,
on the left side of this
diagram, the build test
and deploy when we're
building a new capability,
I guess like when you're starting that out
and when you're scoping it and
when you're checking things
into code, you might
have an idea in your head
that something could be a SEV One later
or a critical service later.
How do you bring your
operational model schema directly
into the beginning of
that lifecycle as well?
- Yeah, so, well thankfully we
have some incredibly talented
engineers on our platform
engineering team such
that you can't get a repository
without actually defining
what some of the operational
metadata is associated with it,
especially the business function
and taxonomy associated with it.
That's normally something that engineers,
leaders are capable of doing
relatively independently,
as long as you aren't
creating naming conflicts
and we never have those
in engineering either.
But when it comes down
to functional impact,
so can this create a SEV One,
can this create a SEV Two?
How does it tie into the
rest of our ecosystem?
That might not be completely understood
when a repository is being created.
At WBD, we have a application
tiering mechanic whereby we tier
each and every microservice
that happens to come
through tier one to tier four.
Tier one, similar to SEV Ones,
happen to be the most business critical,
and there typically are
services that are tied directly
to those CUJs and tier
one services are capable
of creating those SEV Ones
across the organization.
Tier twos loose impact may
be in the path of A CUJ,
but not exactly critical path.
So they may go down, they
may do what we call fail open
so that it won't have customer
impact in those situations.
And then tier three, tier
four, typically back office
or non-customer facing functionalities.
What we do on a regular basis
is we will actually do a bit
of an auditing associated
with that tiering.
And a lot of it ties back to those CUJs.
We have load tests and fault
injection test automation
associated with those CUJs,
and we will execute those on
a regular basis to make sure
that we've got a clear
mapping of the components
and microservices that
tie back to each CUJ.
This gives us a good understanding
whereby we can check,
oh, hey, now we've got
a tier three service
that's now showing up as
a part of the call path
for our CUJ, we need to reclassify this-
- Right.
- As a part of that process
and then change its alerting structure
and mechanics for being able to create
and triage incidents when
they end up getting set
off and set off alerts.
- I'm sure many of us in the
room have had a surprise,
my service is critical situation
in the midst of an incident,
so I like that this is, you know,
being automated a little bit
more to provide that context
because as you said,
no human being can keep
all of this in their head.
And so it's a nice way to supplement it
so that we can run faster.
So let's say that, you know,
we are getting into an incident, right?
We've released a capability,
we've defined everything correctly,
and we're getting into an incident,
we realize it's an incident, right?
So if it works cleanly,
we have detect, triage,
diagnosing, repairing, and
learning from the incident,
but it's not linear, they all kinda,
you know, work together.
Maybe you think you've repaired it
and you're actually diagnosing
a new incident at the same time.
You all have leveraged a lot
of new PagerDuty capabilities
throughout this lifecycle recently.
Could you dive into what's
been most interesting to you?
- Yeah, absolutely.
I'll hit on a few different points
and try to tie it back
to some of the lifecycle
of the incident management process itself.
So, up at the very forefront,
I don't know if this is
necessarily a completely new
capability within PagerDuty,
but a big value add that we get is
with the PagerDuty noise
reduction capability.
This is something that all of
our services get by default,
and by and large, most of our developers
probably don't even know that it exists,
and that's how good it happens to be.
For every service that exists,
microservice, we have a
technical service in PagerDuty,
and each of those technical
services will automatically
merge alerts from that
microservice if they happen
to meet existing criteria.
So, if it happens to be
very similarly named alerts
that come in, same
summary, same description,
it'll automatically condense those
into a singular incident as no operator
or engineer wants to be
opening up their phone
to acknowledge 15 different incidents
that have all stemmed from
the exact same alert path
over the past three minutes or so.
So, that has been a huge boon.
We've seen about a 40 to 50% reduction
in incident creation due to
that noise reduction process.
So, big value add upfront.
Going into some of the
other capabilities, again,
just from the detection point of view,
we've leveraged the
operational, what is it?
The operational dashboard, the-
- Ops console.
- Operations console.
This provides a near
real time refreshing view
of filtered incidents.
It's something that we've
leveraged pretty heavily
associated with major launches.
These are situations where
you're probably going
to have, not just engineering,
but product business folks
that may be interested in
understanding the health
and wellbeing of the new
capabilities that are going live.
And the operations console
gives us the ability
to easily filter to pre-described
data sets associated
with incidents and then give those
to groups across the board
during these critical launch windows
so that you can find out
if we're launching HBO max
and a new country in EMEA,
we can find all the incidents
that pertain to that just based
on the title or description
or metadata associated with that incident.
So, we've seen a lot of value with that.
The third item that I'll
talk about is custom fields,
which I know is a fairly recent
capability within PagerDuty.
This has been something that
we've been clamoring for
for a bit because we
always want to be able
to add additional metadata
to our incident tickets themselves
because we find that
we're very, very analytics
and data driven at WBD.
So the more metadata that we
can attach to those incidents
and then gain insights into
over time, the more learnings
that we can gather and the more we can do
to make our systems more
reliable at the end of the day.
So we've utilized those custom fields
to track things like blast
radius, we automate the count
of customer support
tickets that are associated
with a particular incident
and we also leverage it
as a control mechanism
to kick off advanced
workflows that in the case
that somebody for instance,
wants to escalate an incident
to a SEV One, we make sure
that we've got enough data
within those custom fields
to actually assure that it is a SEV One.
Like I mentioned, we've got
a lot of extra processes
and practices associated with that.
So we don't wanna be in a position
where an individual developer
or somebody with the ability
to create a new incident
jumps it up to a SEV One
because they think it's a support request
and they want high priority
because that's going
to trigger an executive
or VP to get onto a line,
executive communications
go out, et cetera.
So we've leveraged a combination
of those advanced workflows
as well as the custom
fields to make that happen.
- Okay.
Yeah, and and what I like
about that too is, you know,
you were bringing up earlier
around in some incidents
there might be folks DMing
or calling people or
clamoring for information.
And so this puts some of that
right out in the open, right?
And so that they're all
operating under kind of a source
of truth as much as possible
and asking questions that align
with what's going on in the
middle of a situation as well.
- Without a doubt.
This has been a big part of some
of the cultural shift
that we have within WBD
is that the PagerDuty ticket,
the notes, the information
that happened to be in there is the source
of truth for our incident.
So if the information isn't
there, then it's not something
that's associated with the
timeline of the incident,
it's not the relevant information.
We'll certainly source
information from Slack,
but we're not going to point
a net new leader or developer
and say, "hey, go read through the reams
of Slack documentation
that happen to be there."
Instead, go to the PagerDuty ticket
and that's where you'll be able to get
the information that you need.
- And, we touched a little
bit on this in the beginning,
but you know, you've had to
do a lot of cultural changes
around this as well, and
like, as businesses grow
and as businesses come
together like that, you know,
we'll keep evolving.
I'm curious how, you know,
you mentioned you involved
different stakeholders
in the room, but how
did you help engineering
and teams understand how their definition
of reliability was changing and evolving
and maybe how their processes might be
changing and evolving too?
- So, it's always a
difficult problem to solve,
to convince people to do
a thing that you want them
to do when they're very happy with
what they happen to be doing, right?
So the big thing there is the
what's in it for me, right?
The more that we can translate our message
and what we're looking to do into things
that will help those teams
out drive value, reduce,
reduce toil, those are the
ways that we get those wins.
So typically what we'll do is
we'll find business partners,
engineering partners, that'll
be those early adopters
that are incentivized or understand,
hey, I can see the value
in what you're trying
to accomplish here, to
start the snowball effect
to get folks on board.
So, when it came to a lot of
the changes for technology
and commonalities
associated with processes,
even though we had
engineers, process leaders,
business leaders that had
very different opinions
across the board, we were able to get some
of those folks up front that understood,
hey, at the end of the day,
if we all marched to the same drumbeat
and row in the same direction,
we're going to be able
to accomplish a lot more and
it's going to be better off,
not only for me as an individual,
but also the broader organization as well.
- Yeah, absolutely.
I like the, what's in
it for me, framing it.
What were patterns you were looking for
with those early partners that told you
that they would be more
incentivized to try this out
with you and sort of partner with you?
- Ideally, some excitement.
So sometimes there are just some folks
that are just general
early adopters, so they-
- Sure.
- I don't have favorites, for
anybody at WBD that happens
to watch this at another point in time.
But, certainly within an
organization you'll be able
to find some folks that typically want
to be at the forefront
of net new capabilities,
new functionality and
processes that can get on board
and provide honest feedback.
That's something that's critical.
You don't just want folks
that are there to be, yes,
I wanna be an early
adopter, I'm never going
to provide you any feedback
and whatever ends up going
through, this is great
because I can add it to my resume
or I can add it to, you know, my delivery
and performance review
at the end of the year.
That's not the point.
You want folks that are early adopters
that can also provide good
feedback on what you're trying
to accomplish so that your process
or your technology ends up
actually becoming better
through their involvement.
And thankfully at WBD, we've got a number
of different service teams
that we've been able to make
that work with on a regular basis.
- Amazing.
We've talked a lot about
this lifecycle in context
to, you know, a new and
novel incident and a SEV One,
but what about when it is a
little bit more well understood?
You know, you've mentioned reducing toil
and how you're leveraging
some of our products to do
that right now, but I'm
curious, like how you see
this cycle working in a more
well understood situation
and the role that you see agents playing
or how you're even using them now.
- Yeah, so I've talked a
lot about different agent
interplays in our incident
management lifecycle now.
So whether it happened
to be the filtration
through noise reduction
to the additional context
and understanding to the,
maybe I didn't mention it,
but the automation of
status updates as well,
those all factor into that life cycle.
I think if I were to broadcast out
by three, six, maybe 12 months out,
almost seeing a fully AI
landed incident management
lifecycle whereby an incident
is automatically identified
through alerts, threshold-driven
incident management,
incident generation to status updates
being generated automatically,
and then you end up having
people still in the middle mostly
for that thumbs up of,
hey, this looks good
to make sure things that move through.
When it comes to mitigations,
mitigations to me are
still in a little bit
of a scary space, right?
I don't think anyone here is going
to give an agent cube cuddle access
with admin credentials
right off the bat, right?
Maybe, maybe not.
Many of you may be much
more daring than I am,
but it's certainly not something
that I've would necessarily
hand directly to an agent.
Now, if you happen to have
workflows that are well-defined,
that may be in your operational toolkit
that you can hand off to the agent
whereby this is a safe action
and it happens to have
appropriate guardrails set up,
that would be a good place to start.
You know, just giving admin
and full create, update,
delete capabilities,
dangerous domain at this point.
So, what we're doing is
actually investing a lot
in what those workflows are right now
for things like being able to
shift traffic between regions
for being able to restart pods
and things along those lines.
- You know, it's interesting,
I don't know if any
of the folks in the room were like, yeah,
I would do that to his question,
but I think people internally
and people across different
companies might also have
different interpretations
of what is risky versus
what is not risky to
have an agent help with.
And I'm curious, like, you know,
you talk about customer trust in relation
to reliability and customer experience,
but how do you think we can internally
and how do you internally
help people build trust
with the agents to know which
actions should be taken versus
which should be left to the human?
- Oh, well I think the good
news is is that assuming
that you have an application
or systems that have been
in production for a while
and have had a history of
incidents in the past is,
unless you're a startup
that hasn't launched yet,
you're going to be there at
some point in time, right?
We all have a huge test bed effectively
that we can point agents at
and we can do back testing
associated with that, too.
So as I've been talking
through these different agentic solutions
that we're utilizing internally, many
of those we have then utilized internally
and pointed at historical
incidents to validate,
do they provide the same
response as what we did
as a part of that incident?
So that severity
classification matrix agent
that I was talking about before,
before getting started with
that, we ran through a number
of different incidents that were submitted
by customer support, by a
product, by other engineers,
and parse that into the agent
and then validated did it
come out with a severity
that we eventually landed at.
Similarly, you have different types
of status updates and information.
You know, incident history is something
that we all have and most
of us have a very durable
data set that you can play with.
So you can leverage that to
your advantage with building
that trust in the agent
because you can tweak the agent,
you can adjust the prompts
and the set that's associated
with them to improve
that accuracy as much as
you're comfortable with.
- So, when you do start building trust,
and I imagine the trust
will increase over time,
it might decrease in certain
areas depending on, you know,
the nuance and novel
situations that we run into.
How do you see, you know,
the post-incident review process
playing a role in that world?
- Yeah, so, this is an
area that I'm really,
really excited about because
I think we've got a huge
opportunity for leveraging
agents in not only the generation
of post-incident reviews,
but also in adjustments
to those agents based on those
incident reviews themselves.
- Hmm.
- So let's dive into maybe the opportunity
for the post-incident review first.
You mentioned it multiple times already.
Incidents are complicated.
Creating status updates are complicated.
Creating a incident review for something
that took about an hour
and a half to resolve,
incredibly complicated.
One of the most valuable things
that you can do as a part
of a incident review process
is construct a timeline,
an accurate timeline
of what was happening.
And that can be very, very tough
because you're relying on humans
to reconstruct information
based on historical metrics,
logs, conversations, you name it.
You throw an agent at that
history, at a transcript,
at that information, it can print out
and create a timeline
very quickly for you.
And something that would've
taken a operator engineer hours
and hours to create, an
agent can crank it out
in a minute or so, right?
So, huge value in being able to do that
and unearth a lot of learning
that people just won't be able
to do themselves because
you've got a short term cache
and that short term
cache can become corrupt.
And you can remember,
you can misunderstand
and not fully see how things panned out,
but an agent will actually
pull through a lot
of the information, assuming that you have
that information handy.
And it can also point out things
that you might not have
understood to begin with.
So this is an area that
we are investing in
and being able to pull in
some of this information,
whether it be through
transcripts, whether it be
through chat logs, et cetera,
to synthesize that timeline
to be able to better understand
what happened during an incident.
We found that that has
been very beneficial,
especially for some of our most severe
and most complicated incidents so far.
Now, the additional benefit
is being able to then turn
that reflection back on the agents,
because as you're going back
and you're utilizing agents
for your incident response
process, you'll also want to use
that post-incident review to understand
how you can improve your agents.
Again, going back to tweaking
of prompts, being able
to understand, did we get
the same status update
that we wanted as a part of this output?
Was it recommending the remediation
that we expected at the end of the day?
So, big benefit in that space too.
- Yeah, and even, you know,
taking those learnings into the beginning
of the software development
life as well, even
before an incident takes
place, just to have some
of that context, I could see being useful.
- Absolutely.
One of the first use cases
that we explored was
actually pointing an agent
to our historical post
incident review report library.
You know, we've got dozens of those
and we wanted to better
understand systemic issues.
Typically, when folks go
into a post incident review,
and I'm not gonna ask you to
raise your hands, I've done
that like 12 times so far during this,
but most of you have
probably been in a situation
where you've got blinders on, right?
Where you're focused on this incident,
you may not be thinking about an incident
that happened a week
ago, or three weeks ago,
or four weeks ago, or
potentially an incident
in a completely different business domain.
Oh, but there's a connection between them.
There's some similarities.
So, what we started doing early on
was pointing agents toward
this incident review library
to tease out what are some
of these commonalities.
One of the questions that we asked was,
why aren't we auto detecting
as many incidents as we want?
We have too many manually
detected incidents.
So what the agent was able
to do was actually parse
through hundreds of incident reports
and was able to unearth through
the unstructured narratives
that folks had provided to
indicate that, hey, it isn't
because we aren't alerting on 500 errors
or latency metrics or
anything along those lines,
but we were actually running
into a lot of novel situations
where we would have, what
would be considered appropriate
business reactions that
were inappropriately placed.
We were hiding a UI element
when we shouldn't have.
It wasn't an error scenario,
it was just a inappropriate use
of a particular requirement
in that circumstance.
So what we were able to
do was take that back
and then start thinking about
how do we translate those
requirements into a stronger error
signal, and are there areas
where we could potentially
have mismatch requirements
where we aren't generating a 500
or an error log in those scenarios.
So those were some of the
ways that we were able
to take some value out of that.
- How did you, you know, with the patterns
that you saw in the
opportunities for improvement,
how did you prioritize
some of those changes?
- Yeah, so a big part of what we do
within our operational
excellence program is we
run a weekly operational
excellence business review
where we'll actually reflect on all
of our operational measures,
whether it's time to mitigate,
time to acknowledge, auto detection rate,
but we also use this as an opportunity
to share operational learnings
across our engineering
organization because we have members
of our service development teams
from across the board
present during these.
So at the very end of some
of these sessions, we would
share the learnings, we
would drive the action items,
we would then align these
to typically the actual celebration
or post-incident review
processes and those action items.
We actually had SLAs that are defined
for when they're expected to be completed.
So we were able to roll
that into the operational
excellence program itself,
attach them as action items to COEs,
and then let the process
take it off from there.
- Awesome.
You know, you've talked about a few things
that you are doing with
agents and your operations,
and you talked about a few things that
are going to be going forward.
What are you most excited
about on your AI roadmap?
- Yeah, so I think going
back to the ability
to have agents interface
with all of our data sets
and to an extent run an
incident almost on autopilot,
going back to what I was saying before,
getting to a point where
post incident detection,
an agent can quickly analyze
your observability data.
Let's say that's one agent
pointed toward MCP servers
for things like Amazon managed
Prometheus, OpenSearch,
another that happens to
be pointed to data points
associated with recent deployments.
Another pointed to data for, you know,
previous post-incident reviews
and runbooks, you
effectively have your own
mini operations team at your disposal.
- Yeah.
- And you just need a human
in the loop to make sure
that there's no goofiness
that's happening in the mix.
But that's no different than what we do
with people today, right?
We have individuals
that are looking at the operational data,
they have their own context,
they have their own understanding
of what's happening,
and you still have these
coordination pieces.
So, agents help step in
and help out as a part
of that process, too.
- Amazing.
Well, we've had a lot of discussion today
around how we can leverage AI
and automation more
readily in our operations,
especially when we've had
organizations that have been
around for a long time too,
and we have maybe developed things
that didn't use that, right?
And so we're evolving over time.
And so if, you know, we
had to summarize today,
some of the key things
I think you shared, one
of them were pointing LLMs
towards your history, right?
Towards your previous incidents
and your process in order to build trust,
but also some of this might
not be visible to the human eye
and it might help point to things
that we might not be recognizing,
which it sounds like you did
in the last example you gave.
- Yeah, absolutely.
There is a treasure trove of learning
that you all are already sitting on.
I can guarantee you that.
And if you start pointing agents to that,
they can help you unearth that.
And going back to that
example that I gave you,
it would've taken hours,
days, frankly, for an analyst
to parse through all of
that information themselves.
We were able to do that
effectively in an hour. Right?
- Yeah,
- So, huge benefit in that space. Right.
- And, a key thing throughout
our entire conversation
today was the foundational data set
that you invested in right
at the very beginning
and how imperative that is
to even be able to use AI
so that you are getting quality outputs
and aligning folks around that.
And, that can actually end
up increasing the frequency
of being in well understood
situations rather than treating
them as if they're new and novel
and interrupting people's time.
- Yeah, absolutely, I mean, structure
and organization makes things
more efficient, not just
for humans, but also
artificial intelligence
and automation as well.
So, establishing that foundation,
building that vernacular
and classification capability,
while some may say it's boring, I love it.
I'm a nerd in that way.
It is something that pays off
dividends at the end of the day.
- Yeah, it helps everyone
run more smoothly
and probably, not just resolve
incidents more quickly,
but develop things more quickly as well,
because you're operating
under a baseline expectation
that is, you know, roughly the same.
And, a lot of folks already
have current incident processes
that they're using and maybe evolving
and you did as well, right?
And you had mentioned using agents
to reduce context switching
and coordination costs, like using agents
to maybe catch up on what's
going on with a situation
or remember the processes
to follow as well.
How would you recommend
others think about that?
- Yeah, so I would take a look
at your incident lifecycle
and see what are the points
where you are seeing the
most toil, the things
that are distracting from the
point of mitigation, right?
Top priority has to be
mitigate the incident.
Those are things like communication.
Those are things like that individual
or leader that joins the bridge
and asks for a status update
that brings everything
to a screeching halt, right?
The more you can put agents
in automation in play
to be able to mitigate
that and keep folks focused
with their eyes on the
prize, the better off.
So, I think for many companies,
you've got this opportunity
to start pointing agents
to those conversations, point
agents toward that data,
point agents toward those incident reviews
from past history to be
able to provide input
and start chipping away at
the toil that's associated
with the incident management lifecycle.
- Amazing.
Well, we have about three minutes left,
so we probably have
time for some questions
if folks have any for Tom
or about some of what-
- [Tom] Nora, too.
- [Nora] We've been implementing.
- This is so exciting.
So, we're actually in the process
of rolling out a new
service health framework
across all of our applications.
This is a standardized way of being able
to author service level objectives
across our microservices,
their infrastructure, and then roll that
up to the CUJ level as well.
Because our end goal is to be able
to understand the historical health
and wellbeing of everything from the level
of customer impact, all the
way to the smallest level
of microservice at the end of the day.
So, the framework enables us
to define, quite simply, like
what our healthy responses,
what are unhealthy responses,
and then being able to use that,
create percentage based styles associated
with those service level
objectives based on the mapping
to the CUJs and the
tiering of the services
that would then correlate
back into automated incident
severity generation in those situations.
So, you know, tier one
service that's attached
to our playback capability,
if it's violating its SLO,
SEV Two, potential, easy escalation
up to a SEV One in that circumstance.
- All right, well we are at time,
but thank you so much,
Tom, for your time today
and for your partnership in general.
Really appreciate it and thank you,
everyone for joining today.
- Thank you.
(audience applauds)